-Our first guest tonight i
an Academy Award
and Emmy-winning actress
who you know from films like
"If Beale Street Could Talk"
and shows
such as "The Leftovers"
and "Watchmen."
Her film "One Night in Miami
is available
on Amazon Prime video now.
Let's take a look.
-Can't nobody else understan
what it's like being one of us
except us.
-One of us?
-You know.
Young, Black, righteous,
famous, unapologetic.
♪♪♪♪
-There's going to be a targe
on your back.
-It was going to be there,
anyway!
This ain't about civil rights.
Those activists ain't do squat
about them four little girls
that got bombed in Alabama
That's why they preaching
to a deaf congregation,
because they are giving Blac
people what they really want
♪♪♪♪
-What's that?
-What you have,
but take for granted.
♪♪♪♪
Power.
-Please welcome back
to the show Regina King.
How are you, Regina?
-I am doing alright, Seth.
How are you?
-Good. I would love to say
it's nice to have you here
but, of course,
"here" is in quotes
and this is now the second tim
you have joined us remotel
since this all started
and so I just wanted to sa
thank you
and how much we appreciate that.
-Well, thanks for having me.
I can't believe that like
our anniversary is
on Zoom again.
It is very strange.
Something that was not strange
for me because, look,
you are a very accomplishe
dramatic actor
and, of course,
a director, now, as well.
I am of an age where I kno
you as a comedian, first,
and it was so thrilling
to watch you on "SNL."
Did you enjoy that experience?
-I did.
I did.
I mean, just all praises
to the writers and the actor
and just the entire
production team.
I was just blown away.
I feel like I can never, ever,
ever, ever, ever in my lif
say anything about something
that may not be funny to m
on "SNL"
because what they do to brin
that show to us every week
is nothing short of a miracle.
-Yes. I had the same experienc
when I started working there
because I think, like everybody,
the show,
we feel like it belongs to u
and you're critical of it.
You love it and then there
are other times you don't.
And then, you show up
and you try to do that job
and you think, "Oh, okay,
okay, I'll shut up now."
-Shut all the way up.
[ Laughter ]
-You were nominated
for a Golden Globe
and you looked wonderful
in your beautiful dress,
but your dog Cornbread
kind of stole the day.
Are you jealous of how muc
attention Cornbread got?
-I am not.
Listen, Cornbread
is 15 years old.
He deserves all the attention,
to just be hanging in ther
and representing
for the senior dogs.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you did a great job
and you did a fantastic jo
with the film.
This is based on a stage play.
Were you familiar
at all with the play
before it first came
across your desk?
-I was not.
I was not.
Reading the screenplay
was my introduction to it.
I guess I must've been off
working somewhere,
because, usually, you know
I'm up-to-date,
when it comes
to the theater scene in L.A.
because it's so small.
But I read the screenplay,
which was written
by Kemp Powers,
who also adapted his play
to the screenplay,
and I was just blown away.
-So this is an evening
that happened,
but it's obviously
a fictionalized account of i
and it's about four very famou
Black men in the '60s.
And, even though
it takes place in the '60s
it does obviously tie in to what
we're going through right now.
Do you feel as though
you were both making a movie
about the past, but also
that it was very urgent,
in regards to what's happening
in the present?
-Yeah, I mean, you know,
actually,
that was one of the things
that appealed to me,
when I read this script,
that it was relevant.
I mean, unfortunately,
these conversations
are conversations
that Black people
have been having
before that night in 1964.
And so the the dialogue,
the story was always relevant,
but it was just
what happened last year --
we were in the middle
of a pandemic
when George Floyd's murder
was captured on video
and the world was watching
So, it made something
that's always been relevan
for Black people urgent
for the film to come out.
-I imagine one of the trickies
things about a film like thi
and directing it
is getting the casting right
because you're dealing
with four, you know,
historical figures
that everybody
has seen so much film on
and other actors
have played so famously.
You nailed it,
but was that something that,
when you first took it on,
you knew would be a challenge?
-I did. I did, but I knew
that it was an opportunity
Look, I'm an actor.
I love to act.
I love being part
of the thespian community.
so I knew that it was goin
to be for actors that understood
the responsibility
that they were taking on
and that was
the biggest joy for me,
just watching Kingsley, Leslie
Aldis, and Eli just shine.
I felt like
I was the fifth wheel.
I've never been so excited
to be a fifth wheel.
[ Laughs ]
-It really is great
and, you know,
obviously,
we've seen a lot of these,
you know, figures
in biopics before
and I will say, as a viewer,
it's really nice
to just watch them
in sort of one snapshot of tim
and I think that makes it
also more, you know,
unique than anything
we've seen before as well.
As someone who's been
in show business
for as long as you have,
I'm wondering if directing
was something,
you know, when you were a kid --
and, obviously, you know,
you started in in sitcoms --
did you think,
"Oh, I would love to be
behind the camera one day,
or was that something
that sort of took a longer tim
to come to that conclusion
-It took a longer time to come
to that conclusion.
I think I was picking up
things along the way.
You know, sometimes you don'
realize you're the sponge
until later on in life.
But I'm glad
that I was absorbing all
of this information
and I've been with --
I've had just the blessing
to work alongside
some real powerhouses
and I feel like
I was being groomed,
if you will, if you could sa
that in a positive light.
-Let's take it back.
Let's take back that word
[ Laughter ]
and use it as a positive.
-Yes. Yes.
And I would say,
somewhere around 30, 35,
is when I just really starte
taking in all of the different
jobs, if you will, that brin
a story to us, you know.
So often, we only hear
about the director,
we only hear about the actors.
But I started seeing how the
director gets the opportunit
to work with everyone --
the production designer,
the wardrobe designer, the DP.
And just I would say
around that time
is when I really started
paying attention
and feeling like it
was something that, you know
a person that's enthusiastic
about control,
might be a good space to be.
[ Laughs ]
-You're doing
something else that,
as soon as I heard
you were doing it, I thought
"Oh, that's a very good us
of one's time,
during trying times,"
which is you're watching a lot
of old "Golden Girl" episodes.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Gives me just joy.
It just makes you feel like,
you know,
everything may be alright
in the world, one day.
-You know, when I watch
an old "Golden Girls" episode,
my takeaway is, "This script
must've been eight pages,"
because the laughs between the
punch lines are so long.
[ Laughing ]
I'm like, "How? This must be
the shortest script ever."
It's just like setup,
punch line,
laugh for a full minute,
and then they move on.
-But they're genuine laughs.
They are genuine laughs.
It's not like, you know,
a laugh track.
That's people cracking up.
-Yeah, it really is.
I mean, again, your cast of four
does a great job
in "One Night in Miami,"
but that's another cast of fou
that I would put them
up against --
the Golden Girls
versus "One Night in Miami."
[ Laughs ]
-Hey, that's a pretty solid cast
to go up against.
-In the brackets
in the March Madness
of Best Four-Person Cast.
Hey, thank you so much.
It's always
so lovely to see you.
I really appreciate your time.
-Always so good to see you, too.
Give your wife a hug for me!
-I will, of course.
She'll be thrilled to get it
"One Night in Miami"
is available
on Amazon Prime video now.